hairdo that inspired a 12 year old to
give back to others alan balks grew a
mullet when the pandemic began and then
entered a hair competition what he
decided to do next moved his family and
his town meg oliver traveled to
jonesboro arkansas to meet the boy with
a big hairstyle and an even bigger heart
during the pandemic sixth grader alan
baltz found two passions mountain biking
with his parents and twin sister alice
and a new hairdo
why did you choose a mullet i just chose
mullet because
i'm like hmm what would really embarrass
my sister the most
oh wait i'm all lit the boltz family
lives in jonesboro arkansas like parents
across the country lisa and derek were
desperate for creative things to do in
2020 we
started doing crazy things with our hair
alice did her hair teal i went red allen
did a mullet and my husband did a
mustache that was terrible what started
as a way to pass the time morphed into
more than a mullet for alan he added a
faux hawk with lots of gel and then the
curly perm he went for a perm to look a
little bit like mario lopez do you know
who mario lopez is no how did you feel
about the mullet at first i was really
questioning my parenting skills and
allowing it to happen but when a friend
told them about the usa mullet
championship everything changed i
thought i cannot believe this is a real
thing
when you first heard about the usa
mullet championship did you want to
enter when i heard there was like twenty
five hundred dollars i'm like i'm just
gonna donate it to foster care if i win
why did you want to donate it to foster
care i was in foster care and i know
completely how it feels in 2014 allen
and alice were in the foster care system
when they came to live with leslie and
derek we expected it to be a two-week
thing and then they would go to another
placement two weeks eventually turned
into adoption when you think of the kids
in foster care what do you think about i
just really hope they're feeling
happy and hoping that a family will pick
them just like my mom my dad picked me
my sister as the online mullet
competition ramped up voting was in
allen's favor as word spread he planned
to donate the prize money to foster care
independent donations poured in people
just
kept giving and so the total was about 4
500
that the community has
donated you won
i did not think that i did not know i
was going to win that
after three nerve-wracking rounds of
voting the kid sporting the cool shades
and fresh suit had won the illustrious
title usa mullet champion
i was super surprised
how many people have reached out to you
since you've won
about the whole world the whole world
how does that feel
weird and really good so how long are
you keeping onto this hairstyle i'm
probably until i'm dead this is it so
this is the new year yes it's not going
away no leslie how do you feel about
that oh i think it's great now i've come
to terms with it and
he it's it's who he is now for now the
mullet may be here to stay but for the
boltz family this was never really about
a hairstyle anyway there's a real crisis
right now with foster care
what are you hoping comes out of this
we are hoping that the more people that
hear his story it will inspire them to
use the gifts that they have to help the
crisis if you had one wish out of all of
this what would it be foster care to go
obviously so no more kids being foster
care
he touches your heart destiny allen
donated the 2500 prize money to two
arkansas foster organizations project
zero and together we foster the baltz
family is still debating whether allen
will enter again to defend his title
we're not sure mom is up for another
round
allen is definitely up for it he's doing
a lot for foster care doing a lot for
mullets as well he's committed yeah we
want you to go back that does it for us
this is our haircuts for now we'll see
you tomorrow the mullet may be here